know about Ukraine we know about Israel
but we don't know exactly what's going
on in China and Taiwan we know about the
South China seas and everything going on
over there but what happened in Taiwan
and this is important because they
basically said China no thank you we're
aligning ourselves with the United
States and not they're not the only
country that was formerly part of China
or that part of the world that is
essentially aligning with the United
States and I'll show you with that so
they are not aligned with the CCP that's
what's going on in China I'm sorry in
Taiwan and China is not exactly happy
about this so much so the Philippine
prime minister and the Philippines came
out and they basically congratulated the
the new Taiwanese um president China the
CCP said be careful Philippines quote
unquote you're playing with fire but